[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
i have never
in my life
committed
sexual battery johnny depp is back on
the stand plus he never pushed me kicked
me
or
threw me down any stairs supermodel kate
moss is called to testify and later a
common objection becomes an internet
sensation that's hearsay i guess
what constitutes hearsay but first i had
hoped
when i became president i would not have
to do this
again
another massacre
uvalde texas
president biden addresses the nation
after the tragic loss of life at an
elementary school in texas law on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer we begin
with tragic news out of texas where
nearly two dozen students and two adults
were shot and killed when a gunman
entered an elementary school during
school hours on tuesday
the massacre took place at robb
elementary school in uvalde texas a
small community about 85 miles west of
san antonio officials say the gunman 18
year old salvador ramos slaughtered 19
children and two teachers as he
barricaded himself inside a classroom at
the school
law enforcement broke into the room and
killed the shooter who authorities say
used an ar-15 style rifle in the attack
officials say the gunman legally
purchased two rifles just days before
soon after his 18th birthday one rifle
he used to carry out the attack the
other was found in a truck near the
school police say the shooter crashed
the truck shortly after shooting and
injuring his grandmother before entering
the school a large law enforcement
presence surrounded the elementary
school for hours as families waited for
word on their children
the attack comes just 10 days after 10
people were shot to death in a race fuel
tirade at a grocery store in buffalo new
york president biden delivered remarks
on the horrific school shooting in a
somber address upon his return to the
white house after his first trip to asia
since taking office
i had hoped
when i became president i would not have
to do this
again
another massacre
uvalde texas
in elementary school
beautiful
innocent
second third fourth graders
and how many scores of little children
who witness what happened
see their friends die
as if they're on a battlefield for god's
sake
they'll live with the rest of their
lives
i ask the nation to pray for them
give the parents and siblings the
strength
and the darkness they feel right now
it's a time to turn this pain into
action
for every citizen in this country
we have to make it clear to every
elected official in this country it's
time to act
connecticut senator christopher murphy
who formerly represented the district
that included sandy hook school district
spoke from the senate floor tuesday
pleading for action after the mass
shooting in texas
what are we doing
what are we doing
just days after a shooter walked into a
grocery store
to gun down african-american
patrons we have another sandy hook on
our hands
our kids are living in
fear every single time they set foot in
the classroom because they think they're
going to be next
what are we doing
what are we doing
why are you here
if not
to solve
a problem as existential as this
from all of us at law and crime our
hearts and prayers are with everyone
affected in this strategy local state
and federal leaders the community and of
course the families of students and
teachers at uvalde elementary school
still ahead on law and crime daily day
22 of johnny depp versus amber heard
johnny depp is back on the stand we're
live in fairfax virginia to break down
the actress testimony
[Music]
welcome back johnny depp takes the stand
once again on day 22 of his defamation
suit against ex-wife amber heard long
crime network's jesse weber is live in
fairfax county virginia to break down
the big moments from depp's testimony
jesse
hey there brian yeah as we come to the
conclusion of this trial this is very
much johnny depp continuing his rebuttal
case first up supermodel kate moss
testified via live video link and you
recall this was expected after heard
opened the door by referencing the kate
moss stairs incident while she was on
the stand namely la depp allegedly threw
his ex-girlfriend down a flight of
stairs we're going to show you moss's
response to that later on in the program
but from there forensic psychologist dr
shannon curry came back on the stand and
couldn't disagree more with herds expert
dr dawn hughes's conclusion that heard
showed signs of ptsd and of being a
victim of intimate partner violence she
testified that hughes misrepresented
tests and results and also presented her
own opinions and the self-reporting of
hurt his facts but then it was time for
johnny depp himself to testify once
again and he testified that he hadn't
previously seen the statements of his
attorney adam waldman which make up
herds counter claims that hurd hit him
on the orient express and that he
defended himself against some of the
more graphic and violent accusations of
amber hurt
no human being is perfect certainly not
none of us
but i
have never
in my life
committed
sexual battery
physical abuse
all these
outlandish outrageous stories
of me committing these things
and living with it for six years
and waiting to be able to
bring
the truth
out
so this is not
easy for any of us
i know that but um no matter what
happens i did get here and i did tell
the truth
and i
have
spoken up for
what i've been
carrying on my back
reluctantly
for six years
now let's not forget how important this
is because this is depp's final direct
plea to the jury because after closing
arguments it's going to be in their
hands brian
yeah jesse question about that why do
you think depp chose to take the stand
what does he gain from this he's already
testified once
okay so this is his case right it's his
final attempt to rebut everything that
amber heard throughout including some
more of the graphic accusations that she
levied against him in the in her uh when
she was on the stand it's his chance to
address the counter claims as well and
let's not forget johnny depp by all
accounts did a really good job when he
testified the first time so his opinion
is probably like why not just go up
again try again i have nothing to lose
yeah now he testified to some specifics
like you said he said they had no
connection to his lawyer releasing
statements what does that do to herd's
counterclaim
well it's if you believe it right so he
says that he never saw these statements
from adam waldman until he was actually
sued by amber heard i will say he
appeared very evasive in terms of
questioning on that for example he was
very evasive and kind of argumentative
about if he ever met with the daily mail
with adam waldman something that was
confirmed by adam waldman and he came
back and said i don't recall that now so
the jury might ultimately believe that
he didn't have a connection to these
statements or they will believe that he
did have a connection to it and then it
becomes a legal question if those
statements were in fact defamatory yeah
now jesse herd's team wouldn't call depp
in their case
but do you think they made any points
with him on cross-examination a second
time around
i do i think jay benjamin rottenbord did
a really good job cross-examining johnny
depp caught him in inconsistencies
confronted him with kind of these
disturbing and impeaching text messages
there were photos of course that showed
you know johnny depp's face before he
claims uh amber heard actually hit him
so it was kind of a difficult time he
appeared a bit argumentative it was very
different than when he first took the
stand and you could argue that he kind
of won that back and forth in exchange
with jay benjamin rotten for rottenborn
the first round but you might be
thinking rottenborn won the second round
all right we'll see if he's uh maybe
having second thoughts about going up a
second time but of course we'll leave
that up to the jury jesse stick with us
we'll be back in a second coming up on
law and crime daily our comprehensive
coverage of the johnny depp amber heard
trial continues highly anticipated
witness kate moss takes the stand but
does her story match up with amber hurst
that's still ahead on longtime
[Music]
welcome back supermodel and devs
ex-girlfriend kate moss takes the stand
wednesday giving a highly anticipated
yet brief virtual testimony moss
testified about the so-called stairway
incident when she was dating depp in the
1990s
we were leaving the room
and johnny left the room before i did
and there had been a rainstorm
and
as i left the room i slid down the
stairs
and i hurt my back
how did you
i apologize miss moss please continue
and i screamed because i was in
because i didn't know what happened to
me and i was in pain and um
he came
running back to help me
and carried me to my room and
got me medical attention
did mr depp push you in any way down the
stairs
no
during the course of your relationship
did he ever push you down any stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
or
threw me down any stairs
when he was called to the stand depp
backed up moss's testimony with some
objections from herd's team
mr
took the story
and
turned it into
a very ugly incident
all in her
mind
there was never
a
moment where i pushed kate down any set
of stairs
yet she's spewed this three times before
objection your honor miss heard simply
testified that she had heard a rumor and
that's what's
joining us today is former swat and
detective lisa lockwood co-host terry
austin and lawn crime's jesse weber lisa
the push never happened but it was all a
rumor so what does the jury do with that
testimony
well the fact that when amber took the
stand she was basically saying she had
this vision of it happening so she
believed it to be true of
you know his sister being shoved down
the stairs and she thought oh my gosh
this is the same thing that happened to
kate what was important and what johnny
brought forward is the fact that in his
marriage the situation with kate moss
and the alleged rumors he was the one
who told amber heard about the incident
and what happened to kate moss so she
spun it in a way
when she took the stand to help her and
help her case to show that there was
some type of history with domestic
violence and they haven't been able to
bring anybody forward um to show that
johnny touched or put his hand on
anybody in all of his previous
relationships up up until uh he met
amber hurt yeah maybe depp's team used
that as a credibility argument down the
road terry herd's team chose not to
cross-examine kate moss why do you think
that was and was it a smart move
oh it was definitely a smart move
because listen she was only called to
the stand because heard mentioned her
name usually you wouldn't have that kind
of testimony because it's not relevant
to what actually happened to her it's
whatever happened to kate but she was
allowed on the stand because that door
was open and to cross-examine as far as
this witness is concerned they're not
going to get anywhere her team is only
going to ask her about that incident and
she's not going to deny it she knows
more than anyone else because she was
there so i think it was a good move not
to cross-examine kate and just let her
stand as it was yeah the other point
that i'd add is there are time limits
here maybe they're also looking at that
clock and saying i don't have time to
cross examine her jesse you're on the
ground in fairfax virginia what are you
seeing that we aren't in this trial
so this is very much a spectacle brian
this is very much an event for many
people i mean just before we came on
today i observed a verbal altercation
between a johnny depp supporter and an
amber herd supporter there is a
breakdown here between people on who
they believe in this case when i go in
that courtroom it is a majority of
johnny depp supporters and very few
amber heard supporters this has become
something else this has changed from
when this trial first started into a
movement it has become an event a
circus-like atmosphere people dressing
up in fact i observed someone jump into
the middle of the street to try to get a
high-five from johnny depp as he was
driving away so as much as we are
watching what is happening inside that
courtroom there is so much that is
happening outside this courtroom as well
there is a different feeling here and
you have to imagine that as we keep
saying it is not just the court of law
that johnny depp is fighting this battle
in but the court of public opinion as he
said on the stand today no matter the
outcome he wanted to tell his truth and
he wanted to tell his story yes
interesting jesse as you're speaking to
us we can literally see the signs just
as for johnny passing behind you thank
you for that great reporting as always
jesse when we come back a deep dive into
the hearsay objection depp himself has
poked fun at the phrase but what does it
really mean that's ahead on long crime
daily
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
johnny depp versus amber hearn trial
watchers are quick to know the frequency
of objections in this case primarily to
hearsay law and crime network sierra
gillespie explains what the objection
means and why it's gaining so much
traction
for first time trial watchers the number
of objections in a civil lawsuit can be
startling objection hearsay objection
your honor hearsay who knows objection
leading assisting foundation hearsay
even plaintiff johnny depp picked up on
the frequency of a specific objection he
asked her what she would like
for him to cook
that's hearsay i guess
headline johnny depp allegedly showed up
drunk to movie premiere
but what does hearsay really mean
law and crime legal analyst dina dahl
says prospective attorneys spend months
studying the term there's the general
rule which is that you know if you
didn't say it then it's not good
evidence to be presented in court
it's a best evidence type rule if
somebody else said the statement then
they should be the ones testifying to
the statement and not you about what you
heard but the thing with hearsay is you
have that general rule and then you have
a lot of exceptions to the hearsay rule
and that's why it can be quite frankly
hard for somebody to follow
when a certain objections to the hearsay
will get overruled or sustained
entertainment attorney mitra ahurian
breaks down the rule even further if i
say to you amber heard told me that she
was abused therefore she was abused i'm
offering her statement to me
to prove that she was actually abused
and that's not allowed instead i could
say that amber heard told me she was
abused on this date and i'm not
saying it to prove that she was abused
but i might be saying it in response to
someone saying well why didn't she say
anything about it at the time
right so that's a different purpose for
making that same statement but as doll
explains there are ways around the
hearsay rule in the example though we
saw where johnny tepe's team was trying
to object to hearsay a lot of times we
heard amber hurt's attorney say you know
it's not being offered for the truth
right it's maybe being offered for the
state of mind of the witness and so it's
not that the lawyers i think don't
understand the hearsay rule but they are
trying to get in this what they think
it's really good evidence within one of
the exceptions to the hearsay rule and
that's why the job of basically the
johnny depp's team is to kind of hold
them to
that general rule and say hey well you
know that exception doesn't apply
reporting for law and crime network i'm
sierra gillespie
all right we're talking out of court
statements said for the truth of the
matter asserted or hearsay let's start
with you lisa you've testified in dozens
if not more
trials as a police officer why is it so
important to build a case not based on
hearsay
because you need something else that can
be substantiated a rumor a conversation
without that person there to
say that this is truthful information
just becomes that just a rumor or a bias
you don't know the the loyalty of the
person the incentive is it based on
revenge is there monetary or financial
gain so without that individual there to
actually say yes i did make those
statements
everything else becomes
the famous word hearsay it is just a
rumor and you can't use it you need to
have other information that's why
forensics the texts the emails
voice recordings uh camcorders all of
that is a lot more effective yeah the
way i learned it is basically you can't
cross-examine hearsay you can't verify
if it's true now if it's not for the
truth that's what's called non-hearsay
but there are exceptions like present
sense impression dying declarations a
little list goes on and on but there's
some strategy to this as well right
terry because hearsay may not stay on
the record but it may stay in the ear of
jurors what does it mean to say a bell
can't be unrung in the context of
hearsay testimony
well when a juror is listening to the
witness and frankly even when the juror
is listening to the attorney they hear
what that question is and they hear the
answer you can hear an objection the
judge can even sustain the objection but
if the jury has heard that answer
they're not going to be able to forget
it they're going to think it's the truth
and frankly many jurors think that these
hearsay rules and other rules like lack
of foundation speculation leading
are you know very burdensome and that
they shouldn't be there they want to
hear the truth they want to hear what
the witness has to say they don't care
if it's hearsay so they're going to hear
the answer they're going to hear those
questions and they're going to keep it
in their mind so when it says you can't
unring that bell it means the jury
really has heard it anyway yeah perfect
example lisa's got beautiful little
puppy but that's here to say can't use
it we'll see how it works out thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you